Cole MacGrath is yesterday's news but
just in case you haven't finished
infamous - we're not gonna spoil
anything for you here suffice to say
things got pretty real for poor Cole a
most likely won't be coming back unless
of course it's for some random fighting
game in his place developers Sucker
Punch productions has introduced Delson
road
starve the new infamous second son I
recently traveled to Sucker Punch
productions in scenic Seattle Washington
to learn more about why the team has
decided to give this series the old
heroic switcheroo and to learn more
about how they're bringing Delson to
life but before we get to all that let's
start with the good stuff combat and
superpowers Gelson plays quite
differently from coal and to help
expound upon those differences we
chatted with Chris Zimmerman and Brian
Fleming two of the cofounders of sucker
punch in terms of the gameplay for the
game it does have the heritage of the
infamous series but we do break into a
lot of new areas the most obvious of
which is that as the hero Delson they're
all in the game you're not limited to a
single superpower you end up with
multiple superpowers which we've shown
people Smok we've shown people knee on
their arm or past that
the idea of doing a character with
multiple power sets there are really two
big drivers for doing that the first was
that as we worked on infamous and then
infamous 2 we really developed whole set
of electrical powers but in a lot of
ways we put a lot of pressure on the
player to be fairly sophisticated with
the controller because we wanted to keep
adding you know powers and abilities but
you can't keep adding the buttons and
complexity to the controller to hold
down L to R to triangle and that's left
well you do you get into this kind of
courting mentality and it's very very
things get really what we would describe
as overloaded on the controller and we
really wanted to say hey how can we
definitely have a lot of variety and a
lot of powers for players but not get in
that situation so the idea of hey I'm
using one set of powers when I switch to
another was kind of it was a design
point for us to allow you to have a lot
of variety but do it in a way that
didn't kind of big you're not overwhelm
you all at once yeah I goofed out like
really really big-time the minute that I
saw that we were actually going to be
able to have multiple power set about
power sets because it's just awesome for
us as animators it's like the kid in the
candy store because because really okay
we can think about moving through the
environment a different way per power
you know powers are such an intrinsic
part of what's fun about the game
whether they're offensive or traversal
or you know creative they it's so
important that we give you lots of those
powers and so the idea of having a
character who could draw other power
sits into themselves was a big design
point as well
but what about his backstory and no I'm
not talking about how he got his
superpowers I'm talking about how Delson
the character came to be in the first
place
game director Nate Fox took the reins on
this one in fact we chose on infamous
second son to make a new character for
the game because we looked at trophy
data from infamous to where players
decided to sacrifice whole for the
greater good he thought will honor that
choice we're very interested in how
people make choices and we want to make
them potent it seems like such a rare
occurrence for an established series
like to us to go and swap protagonists I
wrote the endings of the infamous 2 and
I wanted it to be the evil one where he
stayed alive but kind of honoring what
people wanted he said ok we will not do
that we'll do the good ending and that
led us through Delson which was great
because we get an all-new origin story
we get a hero with new powers and as
somebody that may be new to the
franchise it's perfect you don't have
all this backstory you don't have to
know who did what wins we once we had
decided we were making a game and in
Seattle it was a you know we look around
see how Tony said it's got a lot of
heavily grunge music in her you know
influence and his designs and stuff that
started coming out you could say you can
see that I have a character felt like
the operations just for people wanted
yeah it was it was it was like I see how
it was infused with the character did he
always have that kind of like that grown
style yeah yeah actually got an a on
that bridge yeah you actually from
pretty early on it felt like it was a
natural like hey if we're gonna we're
gonna go through the trouble of creating
an entirely new character like let's
marry him quite heavily to the city that
he's gonna be from me
we get to do a lot of digging just to
find out things that personify who the
character is and help us we looked a lot
of videos that people who do tagging
things like that try to get an idea you
know just who those people are and
they're in reality but also we looked at
characters like things we looked at a
lot of Eddie better stuff in his early
days when he was on stage performing and
the way he would kind of interact and
climb we looked at Johnny Knoxville was
a big one um it was it which was great
just because the aspect of you know it's
like well we can imagine what human view
Johnny Knoxville powers will normally
he'll jump off of a two-story building
anyway you give him powers is he gonna
jump off of a 50-story building of
course he is of course Delsin Rowe
wouldn't be complete without the right
voice to bring him to life specifically
the voice of Troy Baker who some of you
may recognize as the voice of Joel from
The Last of Us it's Michael
not yours not ours but it wasn't just
his voice that Baker lent to the
creation of delsin's character just
talking to him prior to even reading any
of the lines for like this is a guy I
know so much more important on this game
than any other one it wasn't just the
voice you know we really since we're
doing this the whole facial capture
process it was we wanted to push in with
the new hardware where you could really
get details coming out that are gonna
actually bring their performance and
their nuances into you know those
cutscenes and so we had to have an actor
that they could carry that you know you
get a B performance you know it you know
it'll be game you know so as you can see
a lot of creative minds and talent went
into bringing second son's protagonists
to life but in the end it'll be you
the player who decides whether or not
Belson is a hero or villain karma and
the infamous series have always been
closely intertwined and if you want to
know more about how your choices will
play out in second son be sure to check
out my feature all about the game's
expanded Karma system over on GameSpot
calm
infamous second son will be released for
the PlayStation 4 on March 21st
[Music]